if you plan on doing meetups with more
intellectuals like Camille and and Sam
Harris who would be your pick um well
I'm going to meet Jonathan hight that
would be good
I really admire his work I think he's a
really good guy so I'm looking forward
to talking to him I'd like to talk to
Thomas soul I think it's soul I think
that would be interesting the rest of it
I have to think more about that I mean
that but those are two that I would
definitely like to talk to you I'm going
to speak with Jacque a Willie I think I
mentioned that so that might be
interesting will there be a third talk
with Sam Harris maybe this time with Sam
is your guest and you taking your gloves
off I don't have any plans for a third
talk with Sam I wouldn't be opposed to
it although I think we I think we
probably got about as far as we were
going to get in our second discussion I
think the two discussions together
actually worked quite well so I think I
think and this is no I'm not saying this
in any negative way but I think a third
discussion might be might be beating a
dead horse and like I'm not interested
in particularly in putting Sam on the
spot and you know and it's also possible
that he would put me on the spot it
isn't necessarily that I would come out
victorious so to speak I mean he's a
very sharp guy and there's many you know
compelling arguments to be made in favor
of atheism even though I think that
overall it's it's it's it's a stance
that lacks I don't think it contends
with its opponent fairly because I don't
think that the atheist community in
general takes the thought of serious
religious thinkers seriously I think
they tend to strawman